nächtelang zermaterten sie sich die
Köpfe im Finanzministerium suchten eine
Lösung aus dem schockurteil die FDP sah
sich bislang als Garant für seriöse
Haushaltspolitik und war stolz darauf
die Schuldenbremse gilt es ist vor allen
Dingen auch ein Gebot der ökonomischen
Klugheit und noch vor 9 Tagen sagte der
Fraktionschef die Schuldenbremse muss
bleiben sie ist wichtig für die
Finanzstabilität versprechen die auf
Sand gebaut waren eigentlich nie um
Worte verlegen räumt das aus seiner
Sicht unvermeidliche in wenigen Sätzen
ein in Absprache mit dem Bundeskanzler
und dem Vizekanzler werde ich in der
nächsten Woche einen Nachtragshaushalt
für dieses Jahr vorlegen schönen Dank
das Wort Schuldenbremse nimmt der selbst
nicht in den Mund denn in diesem Moment
bringt er auch seine eigene Partei in
eine Notlage Landesparteitag in
nordrheinwestfah en für die Mitglieder
der FDP ist die Schuldenbremse eine
Grundüberzeugung nun offenbart der
Tabubruch ihr Dilemma sie verantworten
eine Politik die sie eigentlich ablehnen
und ihre Erzählung als Korrektiv der
Ampel geht nicht mehr auf nun fordern
die Jungen Liberalen liberalere Politik
diese Notsituation liegt aber für 2024
nicht mehr vor das muss man so ganz klar
sagen das sagt die Bundesregierung
aktuell noch nicht ich sage das und
deshalb sage ich auch ganz klar 2024
müssen wir unbedingt wieder zur
Einhaltung der Schul BR zurückkehren und
das sehe ich auch als absolut rote Linie
für die jungberal nicht nur für Sie
Frank schffler selbst im
Haushaltsausschuss bringt einen
Dringlichkeitsantrag ein eine erneute
Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse kommt für
uns nicht in Frage da die harten
Kriterien des Grundgesetzes derzeit
nicht gegeben sind mit großer Mehrheit
wird der harte Kurs ab 2024 beschlossen
ein Druckmittel auch an die Parteispitze
als Alternative bleibt nun sparen für
ihn sind fast alle GEP en Klimaprojekte
obsolet nicht nur die auch müssen wir
darüber nachdenken ob wir am Bürgergeld
sparen können ja es war ein ein Fehler
sage ich mal alle ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge automatisch ins Bürgergeld
zu lassen das muss korrigiert werden
aber auch die Kindergrundsicherung so
wie sie angedacht ist ist aus meiner
Sicht nicht
finanzierbar während es für SPD und
grünum schmerzhafte Einsparung geht geht
es für die FDP auch um ihre Prinzipien
und so stellt sich der Bundestags
Abgeordnete Wolfgang kobiki gegen
Lindners Plan sieht es kritisch der
Abgeordnete mordhors geht noch weiter er
schreibt ich konnte mich auf dieses neue
Bündnis einlassen unter der Bedingung
Schuldenbremse und der Verzicht auf
Steuererhöhung das gilt als Bedingung
zumindest für meine Teilnahme ein Ampel
aus als Drohung es war der Parteichef
selbst der 2012 lieber neue Wahlen als
neue Schulden plakatierte und auch heute
denken das einige
ich bin sehr sicher dass die große
Mehrheit gegen den ampelaustritt ist wir
machen hier nicht den la fontain in
schwierigen Zeiten macht man sich nicht
vom Acker und ich glaube das wissen auch
viele Liberale und warum machen Sie
nicht den lafontin ich finde dass dann
jeder dafür sind wir gewählt seiner
Pflicht nachkommt und seinen Job einfach
macht und da geht man nicht von Schiff
wenn das Schiff schwankt sondern man
sorgt dafür dass es wieder ins Lot kommt
doch er hat 500 Stimmen zusammen nun
muss die FDP ihre Mitglieder fragen ob
sie die Ampel beenden wollen ja oder
nein das Ergebnis ist nicht binden aber
eine Machtprobe also in meinen Augen war
diese Ampel von Anfang an eine Todgeburt
wir verhelfen rotgrüner Politik die
eigentlich dem Land schadet man kann
fast sagen eine
deindustrialisierungspolitik mit
Inflation und steigenden Energiepreisen
und allem und wir verhelfen dem zur
Mehrheit die Lage ist brenzlich
Deutschland steht auf Messers Schneide
und die Liberalen kämpfen um Lösungen
die der eigenen Schmerz Grenze
standhalten ziemlich viel los bei den
Liberalen das besprechen wir jetzt mit
Christian D Fraktionsvorsitzender der
Liberalen im Deutschen Bundestag
herzlich willkommen Herr D
danke ihr Finanzminister musste jetzt
doch wieder die schuldenbrumse umgehen
mit einer Notlage für den Haushalt 2023
nachträglich das ganze nachdem er einen
für verfassungswidrig
geurteilten Haushalt aufgestellt hat wie
groß ist der Anteil der FDP am
Vertrauensverlust in die
also Christian L hat ja klar gesagt wir
müssen rein Tisch machen denn eine
buchungspraxis über viele Jahre in
Deutschland auch von der großen
Koalition praktiziert die geht nicht
mehr nach dem Urteil und deswegen ist es
nur folgerichtig diese Entscheidung für
den Haushalt 2023 hatten wir denn
bislang keinen reinen Tisch wir hatten
insofern kein reintisch als dass eine
buchungspraxis übrigens ja auch in den
Ländern wie wir jetzt feststellen
durchgeführt worden ist wo das
Verfassungsgericht jetzt sagt die geht
so nicht entscheidend und ich glaube das
ist auch wichtig für die Zuschauer ist
ja wie sieht's wirklich an der
schuldenfront aus also macht Deutschland
zu viele Sch schen die gute Nachricht
ist frau Zimmermann die Schuldenquote
geht seitdem Christian nner
Finanzminister ist in Deutschland zurück
also das eine ist die buchungspraxis und
das andere ist tatsächlich wie
Deutschland in der Kreide steht under
stehen wir besser da als zu Seiten der
großen Koalition sehr schlecht stehen
wir aber insgesamt als
Wirtschaftsstandort da da gibt es große
Bedenken auch aus der Industrie die
fordert schon auch umzudenken und
eventuell die Schuldenbremse zu
reformieren ist das nicht vielleicht
doch auch ein Weg ja nicht nur Teile der
Industrie die so etwas sagen sondern
auch die CDU CSU die das mittlerweile
sagt ich bin mir dessen bewusst Frau
Zimmermann dass die FDP mit ihrer sehr
klaren Haltung die Schuldenbremse muss
fest bleiben im Grundgesetz eher alleine
da steht das ist richtig aber das ist
auch ein Grund in dieser Regierung zu
sein denn wenn jetzt CDU CSU und SPD und
Grüne beispielsweise das Grundgesetz
ändern würden dann stehen nur noch wir
dazwischen und die Schuldenbremse ist ja
beliebt bei den Deutschen weil sie sagen
der Staat muss auch Maß halten der Staat
muss auch sparen deswegen wundere ich
mich schon über manche Äußerung bei SPD
und grün wussten wir das war manche
Äußerung aus der unionsfamilie auch von
Minister präsenten jetzt sagen die
Schuldenbremse muss man eigentlich
schleifen und weich machen ich halte das
für falsch die SPD und die Grünen wollen
ja nicht nur eventuell die
Schuldenbremse reformieren sondern auch
Steuern erhöhen ihr Haushaltsexperte
Otto Fricke wir haben es gerade im
Beitrag gesehen sagt auch er woll
Steuererhöhung nicht von vorne rein
ausschließen arbeitet er da mit
Rückendeckung der Parteispitze na Auto
Fricke sagt ja ganz klar erst gegen
Steuererhöhung denn wir sind ja in einem
höchststeuerland und Frau zummermann
insofern ist das nicht das Mittel der
Wahl sondern das Mittel der Wahl ist
dass der Staat maßhält mit dem Geld
auskommt was ihm zur Verfügung steht und
deswegen wir werden in den kommenden
Wochen ich mache mir da keine Illusion
eine heftige Debatte in Deutschland
haben über die Zukunft der
Schuldenbremse aber ich hielte es für
falsch in haushaltsschwierigen Zeiten zu
sagen wir ändern einfach das Grundgesetz
und der Bund kann sich wieder wie zu
groko Zeiten fröhlich Verschulden das
wäre die Fal bleiben wir noch mal bei
den Steuererhöhungen Herr Fricke hat
ganz klar gesagt er kann sie nicht
ausschließen es gibt ja auch noch andere
Wege Gelder herbeizuführen so z.B gibt
es im Koalitionsvertrag den patzus
darüber dass sie klimaschädliche
Subventionen abbauen wollen wäre das
jetzt nicht vielleicht der Moment also
sehen Sie mir nach dass ich jetzt nicht
über einzelne Teile reden werde bei den
klimaschädlichen sogenannten
klimaschädlichen Subventionen sagt das
Umweltbundesamt steht an erster Stelle
der soziale Wohnungsbau weil da Beton
genutzt wird und so weiter also da muss
man sehr differenzieren und niemand will
ja ernsthaft sagen wir schaffen jetzt
den sozialen Wohnungsbau ab aber über
alles muss gesprochen werden keine Frage
richtig ist aber wir wollen eine
wirtschaftsstabile Zukunft haben und das
heißt in einem höchsteuerland verbieten
sich dann einfach nur mehr Steuern zu
erheben um die Staatsfinanzen zu
sanieren sondern wir müssen auf die
Ausgabeseite schauen und das hat Chris
lner zurecht gesagt wir haben kein
Einnahmeproblem sondern die Länder und
der Bund haben eher ein ausgabeproblem
also müssen wir uns auf die Ausgaben
konzentrieren die Ausgaben sind nur das
was den Grünen und der SPD lieb und
wichtig ist was liegen sie dann auf den
Tisch wenn sie sagen es muss jetzt alles
auf den Prüfstand was wirft denn die FDP
in den Ring also Frau Zimmermann wie
gesagt sehen Sie mir nach dass ich jetzt
keine öffentlichen verandung führe das
besprechen wir innerhalb der Koalition
aber eins ist doch wichtig dass unser
Eintritt in die Regierung war damit
knüpft dass auch die Schuldenbremse im
Grundgesetz nicht geändert wird jetzt
kommt sie unterdrück auch von Seiten der
Union aber da ist die FDP sehr klar
fokussiert die Schuldenbremse muss
bleiben und da müssen wir schauen was
wir uns leisten können ich glaube klar
ist wir sind eine soziale
Marktwirtschaft und nur auf Subventionen
zu setzen für Zukunftsinvestition wäre
falsch das meiste Geld in Deutschland
wird von den privaten Haushalten und von
den privaten Unternehmen investiert ihre
Fokussierung auf die Schuldenbremse auf
den Markenkern der FDP hat bisher nicht
besonders gut funktioniert seit der
Bundestagswahl haben sich ihre umfäh WTE
halbiert ist es nicht wirklich Zeit für
die FDP umzusteuern und statt innerhalb
der Ampel die Opposition zu spielen
gemeinsam mit der Ampel jetzt einen Plan
zu entwerfen ja das was sie nahlegen
hieße ja gemeinsam mit CDU CSU SPD und
Grünen das Grundgesetz zu ändern und die
Schuldenbremse zu schleifen ich halte
das für falsch ja das ist vielleicht
keine beliebte Position im politischen
Raum aber wir wissen aus Umfragen dass
die Mehrheit der Deutschen sagt die
Schuldenbremse ist eine gute Idee sie
ist jetzt durch das Urteil noch mal
gehärtet und geschärft worden und ich
halt es für richtig ein Urteil
anzunehmen ist um zetzen anstatt dann
gleich die Debatte zu führen wie es
jetzt unionsministerpräsidenten machen
das Grundgesetz zu ändern die
Schuldenbremse sollte gelten sie ist
auch gut für den Wirtschaftsstandort am
Ende sagt der Fraktionsvorsitzender der
Liberalen Christian D herzlichen Dank
für ihr Kommen ich danke Ihnen